Vladimir Putin President of Russia
superpower leader and now a wanted man
for the alleged war crimes of
deportation of children from Ukrainian
occupied territories entered the Russia
Federation the president of the
international criminal court announcing
that arrest warrants have been issued
for two Russian officials one of them Mr
Putin human rights activists were quick
to welcome the news this is an amazing
day for the many victims of Russia's war
crimes against ukrainians since 2014
because this war has been going on since
then almost a decade
Vladimir Putin is now officially a
wanted man but at the same time the
arrest warrant for President Putin
almost certainly complicates the
possibility of any diplomacy to end the
war the UN in particular is in a
difficult position will the Secretary
General still talk or meet with
President Putin I I don't want to
answer
hypothetical uh questions because as you
know issues of travel involve involve
others we will continue as a general
rule the Secretary General will speak to
whomever he needs to speak in order to
deal with the issues out in front of him
in the security Council the Russian
Ambassador made a blistering attack on
the court
the ICC is a puppet in the hands of the
collective West which is always willing
to carry out pseudo-jurisdiction based
on their orders
123 countries are signatories to the
Rome statute that governs the ICC
they're now obliged to arrest the
Russian leader and send him to the Hague
it's likely President Putin's travel
will now be seriously curtailed
of course an arrest or a trial isn't
going to happen anytime soon but it's
clear the international criminal court
is sending a message not just the
President Putin but to the officials and
Military Officers who work for him that
one day they could face consequences for
their actions James Bays Al Jazeera of
the United Nations